The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
IAIN STEWART: [INAUDIBLE]
effective theory workshop.
So last time we were
talking about renormalons,
and we're going to
continue to do that today.
So we said that typically
in quantum field theory
you have perturbation
theories, but actually they're
asymptotic.
And the kind of growth that
you might expect as some power.
I think I use two different
conventions for this power,
whether it's plus n
or minus n, but that's
just a goes to 1 over a, and
there's a factorial growth.
So we said we could
characterize those series
by thinking about
doing something
called a Borel
transform, and that
makes them more convergent.
Because, basically, we
take the coefficients
and we divide the coefficients
by an n factorial.
So we get more
conversion series.
And it may be that
this thing exists,
or it may be that this
thing exists and has poles.
And if it has poles,
as I've indicated here
on the real axis, then
the inverse transform
might not exist.
So even though this thing is
something that you can define,
you can't get back to f.
And if that's the case,
you can characterize
how the original series was
diverging based on those poles.
And those poles are
called renormalons.
So if we could calculate to all
orders in perturbation theory
and some in quantum field
theory, like a gauge theory,
then we could just
calculate these f's.
We would find that actually
there is this factorial growth,
and we'd be able to do this.
But we can't do that,
because we don't know
how to do all the diagrams.
So in order to give you an
explicit example of what
we talked about
last time, instead
of looking at all the diagrams,
we pick a particular subset
that we can identify.
And that's what we're
going to do today,
at least start by doing today.
Part of our discussion
of motivating
why one might want to
think about renormalons
was thinking about the pole
mass versus the MS bar mass
and showing you
that phenomenology
starts to work better in
terms of the MS bar mass.
And then we even
further than that
and said we should talk about
this thing called the 1S mass,
and we'll come back to
that discussion today.
But I'd like to consider
just the explicit calculation
of the pole versus
the MS bar mass
and show you that you
can see this renormalon.
So if we want to think about
the definition of these masses,
then we have to implement those
definitions order by order
in perturbation theory.
And order by order in
perturbation theory,
we could calculate the f's.
But we need to know something
about the entire series,
and that is too hard to
get the complete series.
So we'll pick out an infinite
subset of that complete series
that we could identify
which is unique.
And of course we should pick
an infinite subset that's
the easiest to calculate.
And the one that we can pick
out that's easy to calculate
is the following--
we look at so-called bubble sum.
So graphs with a bubble, and
then more and more of them.
OK.
So the reason that
these graphs are unique
is because if you look at any
order in perturbation theory,
they're the grass
with the most factors
of the number of
fermions running around
in these bubbles.
So if you call the number
of fermions running around
in these bubbles nf, this graph
has the most powers of nf.
So at each order in perturbation
theory, it's unique.
It's a unique contribution.
And it's pretty
easy to calculate,
because there's only one
type of diagram contributing.
AUDIENCE: What does unique mean?
[INAUDIBLE]
IAIN STEWART: Unique means
that there's no other diagram.
So you might think at
each other in perturbation
theory there's lots
and lots of diagrams.
There's only this
diagram that contributes
to the highest power nf.
It's also gauge
invariant, but it's really
a unique diagram that
contributes to that color
slash flavor structure.
OK.
So obviously an ingredient
in this is the bubble itself.
So if we go back to the
bubble plus it's counter term,
and we say there's a
momentum p going through it,
it's diagonal in color,
transverse in momentum.
It has a factor of an ns nf,
some other numerical factors.
There's a logarithm,
there' constant,
and then there's
some divergence,
but we cancelled the
divergence with a counter.
So the graph would
look like that.
And I'm going to
absorb all these things
into a single logarithm
just for convenience.
So I define the constant
c bar, which is this 5/3,
and then I just put
it into the logarithm.
OK.
So then this is a
geometric series,
so it's easy to deal with.
So G mu nu, which is as
a function of p and alpha
s which sums up this
chain plus counterterm
diagrams where there's
n bubbles here,
and we start with no bubbles.
This n is a projector.
OK.
So this is explicitly
writing out the sum.
And what I've done here
is I've used the fact
that even though I
wrote up nf up there,
I can convert it to beta 0.
So beta 0 was 11/3
C a minus 2/3 nf.
I can solve that equation for
nf and substitute it back in.
And that is a
convenient thing to do,
just because you can think
that these terms are then
related to the beta
0, which has to do
with the running coupling.
In some sense,
what we're doing is
we're saying that even though
we just calculated these nf
contributions, we
know there's going
to be some non-Abelian
contribution that comes along
with it that makes this
really into a beta 0.
Or another way of saying
it is that if you think
about characterizing
color structures,
you could write nf
C a, nf f squared.
Or you could write beta
0 C a, beta 0 squared,
and these are equivalent
ways of representing
the different kinds
of color structures
that can come in
at higher order.
And we're just choosing to do
it this way with the beta 0,
rather than the nf's.
So we convert our
nf to a beta 0.
And it's still a unique subset
of the entire set of terms.
The terms we're not including
our terms like this-- nf C a
or C a squared.
And we're just keeping
these guys, which
is equivalent to this guy.
Foes that makes sense?
Everybody happy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
photon [INAUDIBLE]..
IAIN STEWART: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Where are
the photon propagators?
IAIN STEWART: The
photon propagators.
So the photon propagators
all cancel each other out.
So you get a piece greater
than 1 over p squared,
p squared 1 over p squared.
So the whole thing looks
like a photon propagator,
just with a bunch of logs.
Any other questions?
All right.
So this is already
of the structure
where we could think about
doing the Borel transform.
Because we have a
series in alpha s,
and what the Borel transport
meant was taking that series
and converting it to a
series in the Borel variable,
just dividing by n factorial
and then doing a sum.
So previously, the
way I wrote that,
for the conjugate
variables, we wrote that we
had alpha to the n plus 1.
And if you think about what we
do, we just went to b to the n
over n factorial.
So basically, to
convert from this guy
to this guy, that's what we did.
And we had to take special
care at the first term.
But other than the
first term, we just
had this replacement rule.
Now, it's a little convenient
actually not to do that
with exactly the same variable
but a slightly different
variable that's just rescaled.
So I'm going to use a slightly
different variable here,
which is typical.
So what we'll do is we'll say
that instead of just taking
along the alpha s, we'll take
along with it the beta 0.
And we'll say that the
conjugate variable of that
is u instead of b, but
it's just rescaled.
We're just taking
something along
with the coupling constant.
Which is always we're
always free to do.
It's just a
multiplicative factor.
Now, if we look at
this diagram here,
the factors of the coupling
that we've included
are all the ones that are
attached to the bubbles.
But there's two more-- there's
one here and one there.
And if we're going to make
this replacement rule,
we have to identify all
the factors of alpha s,
because they're all going to
disappear and become u's. So we
have to take these
guys into account too.
We have an extra
G squared, which
I'm going to write in
terms of this variable.
So there's an extra factor
of G squared from the ends.
And if you think
about what that means,
it means that every diagram
that we're considering here
starts with n equals
1, so we don't
have to worry about this
delta function term.
It starts with n equals 0.
There's no term with
no couplings here.
So then it is
literally what I said,
that we just take this factor
and replace it by that factor.
So a Borel transform,
remember, is a transform
of the variable alpha s.
Alpha s goes over to
a different space.
So it's not a
kinematic variable.
It's not like what we're
used to transforming in,
but it's perfectly fine.
For those people that
came in after I said this,
there's no lecture on Thursday.
So let me use the
following notation,
taking that G squared along
with our geometric sum,
and now expressing that whole
thing as a function of momentum
still, and u instead of alpha s.
So I replaced the
alpha s's, and I
get that series,
which we can see
is just an exponential series.
So I can just calculate the sum.
Borel variable u log--
which if you have an exponential
of a log, it's just a power.
So let's organize it that way.
So let me write it this
way So just writing
the exponential of a log is that
thing raised to the power u,
taking the mu squared to the
c bar u, that's a constant.
And then taking all the
factors of p squared,
there is one from here, and then
there's u of them from there.
but I took an extra
one from here,
multiplied on top and bottom
by an extra p squared.
Hopefully I got the sign right.
Looks like it should be plus.
OK.
So this thing is kind of
nice for computations,
because when you stick it
back into our bubble sum--
when you stick this
bubble sum back
into the diagram we
want to compute--
we just have effectively a
modified gluon propagator.
So think of it as some kind
of modified gluon propagator.
Maybe I should write it
in a different color.
So it's just like this, where
we use a different Feynman
rule for that propagator.
So it's not actually--
doing these types of
bubble sum calculations
is not any more hard than
doing a one loop calculation,
you just have to use a different
power for the propagator.
But your Feynman integral tricks
can handle that very easily.
OK.
So it's about as hard as
computing this one with graph.
So let's call this
thing sigma bubble,
and let's think
about calculating it
in terms of the MS bar mass.
And then we also cancel any
one of our epsilon poles, which
we're not really
interested in here.
The 1 over epsilon poles
actually come from--
if we think about what
happened with the variables--
the case u equal 0, which
is the log divergent piece.
And if you think
about what we want
to do in order to
look for poles,
u equals 0 is actually related
to the ultraviolet divergence,
while values u greater
than 0 and u less than 0,
those are probing
these poles that
are off the axis
in the Borel plane.
And it's those power
law divergences that
are probing for renormalons.
And we'll see that they lead
to poles in the Borel plane
through this
modified propagator.
So let's calculate--
the goal here
is going to be to calculate
an expression that
relates to the MS bar
mass and the pole mass.
And that'll be an
infinite series,
and it will be a
function in Borel space.
The alpha s space, that would be
an infinite series in alpha s,
because we've included an
infinite number of alpha s's
in our diagrams.
And if we go over
to Borel space,
there'll be some functional
relationship between those two
masses.
OK, so what's the
definition of a pole mass.
If you go back to the
propagator and you write it
in terms of the MS bar mass--
so you formulated your
whole quantum field theory
in terms of the MS bar
mass, you calculate
that bubble some,
called it sigma,
wrote it in terms
of MS bar mass--
the general structure
of sigma would
be that there is some constant
piece, which I'll call sigma 1.
And then there's
some sigma 2 piece.
And the pole mass is the
place where you demand--
you just have p
slash minus m pole.
So another way of saying
that is that if p squared is
equal to m pole squared, you
set that to be 0, which I can
write as an equation like that.
And then I can square it.
So m pole squared, which
is p slash squared,
m bar squared,
this thing squared.
And if you just think
about what that gives,
this is giving
some equation that
looks like m pole is
m bar, m 1 plus sigma
1 plus the extra stuff.
So let's do that
and figure out what
we get from this
diagram for the sigma.
So it's a usual one
loop type calculation,
except instead of
the gluon propagator,
I have this G mu nu
thing, which at this point
is in alpha space, let's say.
And then I have the
fermion propagator.
And I've taken into account all
the g squareds and the alpha
s's in here.
And so to go to
the Borel space, I
can do that under the integrand.
So I just take g squared
G mu nu bubble k and alpha
s, k being the loop
momenta, and just
send that over to this thing
that I'm calling g squared G mu
nu bubble, which is not a
function of g squared anymore,
but just a function of k and u.
And as long as you're
staying away from u equals 0,
there's no issues
related to the order
of doing those operations.
So at u equals 0, you have to be
actually careful if you really
want to go figure out what's
happening at u equals 0.
But that's actually not
what we're interested in,
so we'll just ignore what's
happening at u equals 0.
OK.
So combine-- stick
in the expression
that we had over
here for this guy,
and it's just some p
squared to a power.
So it becomes a k
So you have k
squared to a power,
you have this guy to a power--
use the usual tricks.
Combine denominators,
do algebra,
and you get some expression
for sigma 1 in Borel space.
And then, from that,
you can construct
the relation between the pole
mass and the MS bar mass.
And it might not surprise,
having done some one loop
calculations that you're
getting some gamma functions,
after the dust settles,
this is what it looks like.
6, 1 minus u, gamma of u, gamma
of 1 minus 2u over gamma of 3
minus u.
So the piece that
we just calculated,
or sketched how you
would calculate, is this.
And then there's the
tree level relation
between these two things,
which in alpha s space
was just that m pole
was equal to m bar.
But when you transform
one to the Borel space,
you get a delta function.
So this comes from--
just that equality
at lowest order
becomes a delta function
in the Borel space.
So now, if you look at this
and you ignore u equals 0,
then the closest pole to
u equals 0 is equals 1/2
coming from this gamma function.
And remember that we
had a kind of notation
for the strength
of a renormalon.
Those closest to the
origin were the strongest.
So the strongest renormalon here
is a u equals 1/2 renormalon.
That strength was
related to the fact
that basically you got something
that would be, in this case, 2
to the n, n factorial.
So 1.2 to the minus n.
And so the guy that's closest
gets the strongest prefactor
through the n factorial growth.
That's where that
naming came from.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there weren't
[? mu poles ?] in--
the only pole in the modified
gluon propagator, was it--
Oh, like, the one that made
the denominator vanish.
But the rest of the
poles came from actually
doing the one with the diagram.
IAIN STEWART: That's right.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: --in the series.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So what you're doing
is you're actually
thinking of probing the
infrared structure in this loop.
That's what the gluon is doing.
And the modified propagator
p squared to the u
is just giving you a kind
of a regulator if you like,
which is the u
that's allowing you
to probe what's the
infrastructure in powers
in this loop diagram, not just
kind of logarithmic divergences
which we usually focus on but
also in power law sensitivity
to the infrared.
So it's like probing
low momentum gluons
with this modified
gluon propagator.
And that's what's
resulting in these poles.
You're probing the infrared
structure of the loop.
So there would be some other
terms that I haven't written.
So let me just comment
that there's actually
a term that's proportional
to 1 over u that would make
it finite at u equals 0
if we're more careful,
when we carry out the
renormalization properly.
And I also wasn't so worried
about anything analytic in u.
So I only was looking at
these gamma functions.
OK.
So if we actually just specify
ourselves to that u equals 1/2,
we can simplify
things even further.
So stick in u equals 1/2.
And if I stick in u to the
1/2, this becomes mu over m bar
e to the c bar over 2.
If I just put this 1/2
in there, all this stuff
with the gamma functions becomes
a minus 2 over u minus 1/2.
So there's a pole.
It's sitting on the real axis,
and we can't do the transform.
AUDIENCE: At this point
can you drop the delta u?
Because you know it's not--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, I
don't really need it.
But just sort of for
completeness I kept it.
Yeah.
If I just wanted to think about
this term, I could drop it.
Yeah.
So let's think about
the inverse Borel.
So we wanted to do an
integral which in this u space
would look like this--
so u is the conjugate variable
to 4 pi over beta 0 alpha s
of mu.
That was what we transformed.
So that's the difference
between our old notation
and our new one.
We just have a conjugate
variable to this thing.
And so this has an ambiguity,
because on the real axis
we have a pole at u equals 1/2.
So there's that
pole at 1/2, and you
have to decide do we want to
go around that above or below.
So I mentioned
this last time, we
could think about going
past the pole that way
or going past the pole this way.
And the fact that we
have to make a choice
means there's an ambiguity.
And if you like,
you can say, well,
it's the average above and below
or that the ambiguity would
then be something like
1/2 going around the pole.
So let's actually look
at what the ambiguity is.
So the ambiguity, well,
if we go around the pole,
we get a 2 pi i.
There's 1/2, integral around
the pole, this factor.
So mu c bar over 2, bar.
And if we put
everything together,
the rest of the prefactor,
there's a C f over 3 pi beta 0,
and there's also
another m bar, which
is this m bar that's out front.
And I combined the minus 2
with the six together, 3.
So the m bars actually
are cancelling.
We close on the pole, stick
that value in everywhere else,
and we get that.
Does anybody recognize this?
AUDIENCE: It's
like an instanton.
IAIN STEWART: It's lambda QCD.
Yeah.
Yeah, it looks kind of like an
instanton with the exponential,
but this particular thing is
actually exactly lambda QCD.
So if we solve this,
and we invert it,
and we solve for alpha s, that
would be the usual formula
for lambda QCD--
alpha in terms of lambda QCD.
So we've just shown
that the ambiguity
up to some constant prefactor
is exactly lambda QCD.
And that is exactly
our physical idea
that we said last time, that
the pole mass has a delta m
of order lambda QCD ambiguity.
And we've just seen
that explicitly
arise from calculations
with this Borel space.
So that's kind of neat Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So Is there a way to
be careful about the pi epsilon
description when we do
these Borel transforms?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because it seems
like you just multiplied
a bunch of p squareds
plus i epsilons
together, and then just
ignored the i epsilon.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
I didn't ignore the i epsilon.
The reason I wrote it as a
minus p squared to the power
was because of that i epsilon.
I didn't write the i
epsilons on the board.
But if I had, it wouldn't
change anything that I wrote.
So the one way I can say
it is that when I actually
did these loop
calculations, I was actually
careful about the i epsilon.
AUDIENCE: I'm not worried
about getting the sign--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --like of logs.
I'm worried about
actually defining products
of distributions right.
Like when you interchange
the order of integration,
presumably you're doing
something [INAUDIBLE]----
IAIN STEWART: You mean
the order of the summation
and the integration?
AUDIENCE: Right.
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
When you interchange that
order, the only thing that you--
so you can do it
in the other order.
The only thing that
actually goes wrong--
and it's much easier to
present it in this order.
This is why I did.
If you do do it in
the other order,
the only thing that will change
is what happens at u equals 0.
So you'll actually
see everything
that we saw, except
that u equals zero,
it'll be slightly different.
And that 1 over u term
that I was talking about,
if you want to get
that right, you
have to think about
the issue of changing
the order of integration
more carefully than I did.
AUDIENCE: But if it's
near u equals 1/2.
IAIN STEWART: Near u
equals 1/2, it's exactly--
this is the right result.
And near any other u except u
equals 0 we're OK.
AUDIENCE: Iain?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So which [INAUDIBLE]?
IAIN STEWART: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Which [INAUDIBLE]
would it be to define--
IAIN STEWART: We don't know.
So the ambiguity-- you have
to make a choice, right?
If you make this choice,
you've picked one definition.
you've picked another.
And I said, we can quantify
the ambiguity in our choice
by thinking about it as
1/2 going around the pole.
That's kind of a
measure of the ambiguity
that we have in
which way to close.
It's an ambiguity.
AUDIENCE: I know.
But when [INAUDIBLE] on
how we calculate it, right?
So when we can m pole,
what do we mean by--
IAIN STEWART: Different
people mean different things.
I mean, you're not going
to see this, right,
unless you got all orders
in perturbation theory.
So order by order in
perturbation theory,
you will never see this pole.
So unless you're
working to all orders--
as soon as you
work to all orders,
you have to make a choice
because of what we just did.
If you work order by order,
there's no choice to make,
and you just order
by order define it
with the usual definition.
So the moral is not how
do we define m pole,
the moral is we
should use something
else other than m pole.
Because m pole has an ambiguity.
So we use the MS bar mass m
bar here for our calculation,
but actually the ambiguity
wasn't depending on that.
It really will show up--
even if we thought of some
other short distance mass
beside the MS bar
mass, we would still
see the same
ambiguity if we tried
to associated it to the m pole.
And actually, this thing
is a unique property
of the pole mass.
It's the pole mass that has this
problem, not the MS bar mass.
Another thing you'll
notice is that when
we went back and looked
at the ambiguity back
in the original
space, in the coupling
space, which is where we
live, then the mu dependence
went away.
We just got something that was
a constant times lambda QCD.
There was no mu dependence.
So the ambiguity
is mu independent.
It's proportional to lambda QCD.
If we looked, on the other
hand, in the Borel space,
at the residue of the
pole, it was mu dependent.
So before we did the
integral, if we just
look at even the
pole as u minus 1/2,
the residue has mu power
in it in the numerator.
And that just went along for
the ride and became this mu.
But when we transformed
back, we had alpha mu there,
and the mu dependence
was cancelling.
And this actually is--
there's one important
fact about this.
So when we express something
like a decay rate, which
we might originally calculate
in terms of the pole mass
since maybe that's simpler, and
we get some series, if we want
to express that, say, in
terms of the MS bar mass,
then what we're
after doing is we're
after actually canceling
a pole in the Borel plane
that occurs in kind of
the series that relates
this guy to the MS bar mass.
And then there's a
corresponding pole
in this series in
the decay rate.
And those have to cancel
against each other.
So you should think that there's
a 1 over u minus 1/2 pole
in the relation of this
thing to the MS bar
mass that we just computed.
And one could also
look at, for example,
bubble chains for this
particular observable.
People have done that.
And if we did that, you'd
also find exactly the same,
u equals 1/2 pole
in that series.
And these are cancelling if we
make that change of variable
here.
I guess I've already said that.
When you do that--
in practice of
course, what you do is
you don't have the whole series.
So what you do is you want
the cancellation to take place
at the order you've worked.
So say I know alpha squared
in this decay rate--
which is true,
people do know that--
and the alpha squared relation.
What you then want
to do is you want
to make sure that the terms,
any large numerical factors
in front of the series,
are canceling out
to order alpha squared.
And there's only
one little caveat
which you have to
be careful about,
and that is that you have to
expand in the same coupling.
So when we do this
cancellation order by order,
you should use the same coupling
constant with the same scale.
So as long as both series--
so you can't, for
example, make a conversion
with the M b pole
with alpha s evaluated
at the b scale or
some other scale.
You have to really do
it at the same scale
that whatever this series
is expressed in terms of.
And you can also think of that
as being related to the fact
that the Borel variable
u itself was defined
as the conjugate
variable to something
that was mu dependent.
So even the definition
of u involves alpha
at it's particular scale mu.
OK.
So I said that in a bit
of a convoluted way.
But hopefully what I'm saying is
clear, even if what I'm writing
is not so clear.
OK.
So same coupling in this series
and the conversion series.
And this, what I've just
said, is also a general fact,
that these poles are artifacts
of splitting up physics
at different scales.
And they will always
be canceling out
observable things.
They're remnants of splitting
up physics in particular ways.
They always cancel
out of observables.
AUDIENCE: When you say
physics at different scales,
is that a proxy for
taking a certain infinite
subset of diagrams--
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
So if you like, we introduced
a cutoff in our diagrams
when we did them.
Right.
AUDIENCE: Like the number of
gluon propagators [INAUDIBLE]??
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
I mean-- right.
Effectively, you
could think of it
like that or the
number of bubbles.
Yeah.
And that was a proxy that
became this u variable.
And that was becoming kind
of a probe for the cutoff
dependence.
So we'll talk more
about that right now.
So what is this?
How should you think
about this cutoff?
So when we remove the ambiguity,
we actually introduce a scale.
And the way you can think
of that is as follows--
you should think
that, in general,
the relation between the
pole mass and some other mass
is some infinite
series which has
the general structure of a
bunch of logarithms perhaps,
and coupling constants,
and some coefficients.
So it's a double
series in n and k.
It starts at order alpha.
So that's why n is
starting at order one.
And just because of dimensions--
if this is dimension 1, that's
dimension 1-- there has to
be something of a dimension 1
that we stick there.
And let's be flexible about
we put what we put there
and call it R.
So this is a general
scheme conversion formula.
We can put any kind of
conversion into that form.
So if we call this
thing here delta m,
then I can also move it to the
other side and write like this.
And then, what you can say is
that if I pick my delta m such
that it's infrared
structure, it's asymptotic
structured alpha, is
the same as the pole
mass, I can set up
something where I
get a renormalon-free mass m R.
So the pole mass
has this renormalon
that we've been talking about.
If I set it up so that
my subtractions also have
the same kind of structure--
so for example, with
the example that we did,
you would need the
nonlogarithmic terms
to be n factorial 2 to
the n, beta 0 to the n--
as long as we have the
right terms in the delta m,
we can construct something
that's free of that renormalon.
Now, in MS bar,
which is what we did,
this R scale is just
the MS bar mass itself.
Which is the running quantity,
but it's evaluated at m bar.
So the formula that
we get would have
m pole is equal to m bar plus
m bar times a series in alpha.
That was the conversion.
So the scale R was
fixed to be m bar.
In this scheme that we
talked about last time, which
is called the 1S scheme,
where we talked about defining
a scheme by thinking about
two heavy quarks calculating
corrections between
calculating perturbatively
the potential between
those heavy quarks
and defining a mass that way,
that's called the 1S scheme.
In that particular case,
you get an extra alpha
that we talked about.
And the corresponding
R would actually
be the m 1S mass
times an alpha, which
is effectively the inverse
Bohr radius for this potential.
But we can even be
more general than that.
We can make this R into
just a free parameter.
We don't have to fix it in the
way that these two schemes do.
We can think of it
as a floating cutoff.
And for any R that we
pick, the ambiguity delta m
will be R independent.
Just like the m bar was
cancelling out when we picked
the MS bar scheme, when
you pick the 1S scheme,
that R cancels out.
And generically, the ambiguity,
which is just lambda QCD,
is independent of R.
So R is really setting a scale.
So really what you're doing
is you're cancelling something
that's happening if you like
it in the deep infrared.
But whenever you
cancel something,
you have to sort of decide
how much of the leftover
do you take.
You're canceling something
at 0, but then you're
taking something
from 0 to something.
And that "to something"
is exactly what this R is.
Just like in dim reg--
my spelling is atrocious.
Just like in dim
reg, when you cancel
the UV pole that's at infinity.
You have 1 over epsilon
UV, but the mu comes in,
and the mu is setting kind of a
soft cutoff on your integrals.
And you think of that as
where you've moved down to.
In the same way, this
R is kind of saying,
you're canceling
something at 0, and we
have to take along with it some
fluctuations up to some scale.
And R us providing that choice.
So we take some infrared
fluctuations together
with the pole mass--
these are the infrared
fluctuations that were causing
the [? stability. ?] They are
[? dressing ?] the pole mass,
if you like, which is like
a point particle mass.
They're making it into a
kind of [? dressed ?] mass,
and they're yielding a
well-defined mass parameter
that then depends on a scale.
So here's the origin.
I think that you include
all the fluctuations
in some sphere around
the origin node to R.
That's the right
physical picture.
So the right
physical picture here
is that when we're
using the MS bar scheme,
we're ignoring powers.
And there was actually
an improper separation
between certain power law terms.
Those power law terms
that you didn't really
see very well in
MS bar can be seen
when you look at the asymptotics
of the perturbation series.
They come back to haunt you.
You can look at the asymptotics
of the perturbation series
using these renormalon
Borel-style techniques.
And you can figure
out how to define
masses that are sensitive
to these problems,
like the MS bar mass.
The MS bar mass has
too large an r scale
to be used for b physics.
The 1S mass is something
that has a small enough scale
that you can use
it for b physics,
although it would have potential
problems for top quark physics.
But you can actually
make the scale
where you're absorbing
the fluctuations up
to a free parameter,
and then you're
good to go with any
physical problem,
because you can choose it to
be an appropriate scale, much
like we choose mu to be
an appropriate scale.
So let me give one
very definite example
of how you could define
a scheme with this R.
So we'll build something that's
where we don't have to do
any additional calculations.
What we're going to
do is we're going
to use the MS bar mass,
the MS bar pole scheme
conversion, and from that we
define the a's that we need.
We can take mu equal to R so
that the log of mu over R is 0,
and then we don't need
any of the other a's.
So then we have a formula
that's a definite thing that
looks as follows--
so we're tweaking the MS
bar result, if you like,
so that instead of
having a fixed scale,
it has a floating scale.
So these are the MS bar values.
And we don't have the MS bar
front, we have an R in front.
And we have R's in
these couplings.
And that's a well-defined
scheme called the MSR scheme.
And in this scheme,
you have a cut off
R that you can just pick as
a parameter and adjust it.
It's just a parameter like mu.
It's part of the
definition of the scheme.
And so this kind of
change here would
be good for doing physics.
This is a good scheme
for doing physics
where you want to absorb
things up to that cutoff.
So you can sort of--
well--
So if you're
thinking about HQET,
you can pick the R to
be say a GV freely,
and it wouldn't care
about whether you're
talking about a top quark or a
bottom quark or a charm quark.
It's just a free parameter.
You can pick it to
be something fixed,
and it wouldn't depend
on what kind of mass
you're starting over here with.
So you're just kind of
decoupling this cutoff
from the mass itself.
All right.
Any questions?
AUDIENCE: So when you wrote
the series in k that you not
got rid of with
this choice, that
was just you being
careful about including--
IAIN STEWART: Everything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
IAIN STEWART: Yeah.
I mean, I was just being
careful about including
all the kind of things
that in principle I
could see in any arbitrary
choice of scheme change.
And in any arbitrary
choice, there's
both mu, which we defined--
that was related to the alpha--
and there was this R showing up.
And we got logs of mu
over R. And in MS bar,
the R was in bar, but you still
had mu showing up as well.
And mu is related to the
running of the MS bar mass.
But in general, the fact
that you have both mu and R
is kind of--
they were separate.
Because you define mu
for the log cutoffs.
And you defined R here for
the power log cutoffs--
the power log divergences.
At the end of the day,
you might as well just
take those cutoffs
to be the same.
And that's what I
just did-- mu equals
R. That gets rid of the logs.
AUDIENCE: Do people
worry about u equals 1?
IAIN STEWART: Yeah, you
can worry about u equals
1. u equals 1/2 is the first
thing you should worry about.
If you want to go to
u equals 1, then you
need problems that have
kind of more information
in perturbation theory.
So if you just have
two loop information,
u equals 1/2 is
usually perfectly fine.
If you have four
loop information,
you probably should start
worrying about u equals 1.
That's just kind of rough.
So people don't
often talk about u
equals 1, though
sometimes they do.
OK.
So I need a little
aside here in order
to proceed with what I
want to talk about next.
And that is I just want
to define for you how
you would define lambda QCD at
higher orders of perturbation
theory.
So the formula we used a
minute ago was leading log,
but we can define lambda QCD
even if we go to higher orders.
And I just want to do a
little bit of algebra, set up
some of the notation in order
to define this thing at higher
orders.
So MS bar beta function--
and we're going to just
work to all orders formally.
And we'll see that we can
construct a solution where it's
kind of obvious how you
would work to whatever order
you want to work.
So let's just
parameterize the series,
even if we don't
know all the terms.
We only up to beta 4.
But let's parameterize the
series as a bunch of betas.
I'm going to call the
cutoff R, because we've
started calling it that.
But I could call it mu.
I just took mu equal to
R. So I can rearrange
that equation in this way--
I can write it as dR over R
is equal to d alpha over beta.
And then I can integrate on
both sides between two values.
And on this integral,
it's just giving me a log.
This integral, it's giving
me an integral over alpha.
So what I'm going
to want to do here
is make a change of variables.
And we'll see the following
change of intervals convenient.
I'm going to make a change of
variables in the integration
to this t.
So I have some dummy variable
that I'm integrating over.
Let's change the
dummy variable t.
And basically that's going
to simplify the lowest order
result.
Because the lowest order result
d alpha over beta of alpha,
well, the beta goes like
alpha squared at lowest order.
So I'm basically making
a change of variable
where this d alpha over beta at
lowest order will just be DT.
That's what I'm doing.
I have to change variables
in the limits as well.
So I call those t1 and
t0 and change variables
consistently everywhere.
And if I do that, this is the
kind of form of the result.
So this is just a Laurent
series in 1 over t.
And the first term, we had
d alpha over minus beta 0
over 2 pi alpha squared.
And that was just minus dt.
So the reason that
this thing here is 1
is because my change
of variable with dt
was exactly taking into
account all the factors
to basically just
make it into a 1.
And there's a sign change,
but I flipped the limits.
So we made the first
term trivial, and then
the higher terms of these terms.
And these b hats we could
figure out what they are.
And they're just combinations
of the beta functions.
So once we expand
the 1 over beta,
we get various
combinations of things.
I think I won't write b3.
We could also do the integral--
pretty easy integral to do.
And so if you want to
write a solution for what
the integral is, you
could say, well, it's
some function that
you get from doing
the indefinite
integral evaluated
at the upper limit minus that
function evaluated at the lower
limit.
And G is just that function.
So doing the integral
of 1 gives t.
Doing the integral
of the other time,
and being careful about what's
positive and what's negative,
I can write as log of minus t.
So t was negative.
And if you look at
my definition of t,
it had a minus sign in it.
So this log is a
logical positive number.
So we have this G of t and
G prime of t is just b hat.
And if we write a formula--
which is not what we're
actually interested in here,
but we might as well
write it anyway--
it's this way.
Just taking that formula
and writing it this way,
then if you think about
what this formula is,
it's an all orders relation
between the coupling
at one scale and the
coupling at another.
It's a formal
relation, because you
need to know the coefficients.
But if someone tells
you the coefficients,
you can plug them
into this formula.
And this is the extension
of the usual running formula
that you would write down
for relating alpha at one
scale to alpha at another scale.
This is a generalization
that includes higher order
terms in the beta function.
So the other thing
that we can do
is we can rearrange the formula
and take account of the fact
that we have R1's and R0's,
and we can make it such
that we have only R1's on
one side of the formula
and R0's on the other
side of the formula
by splitting the
log into two pieces.
And that's what you do
to define lambda QCD.
So we can rearrange
it as follows--
taking an exponent.
So now we only have our R0's in
this part, R1's in that part.
This thing has to be independent
of the choice of the R,
and that's just this
constant lambda QCD.
And that's the generalization
of this definition
of lambda QCD that
we had before,
where it was R0 e to the
minus 2 pi over beta 0 alpha.
Now we have the higher
terms that I just
decoded in this G function.
So if you didn't remember that
formula for the lambda QCD,
now we've derived it.
And we included the higher
order terms as well.
So the next term would be this.
[INAUDIBLE] higher order terms.
And usually you call this
the leading log expression
for lambda QCD, with the
next leading log once you
include that term, et cetera.
But the whole combination
is mu independent.
The mu independence of this term
is only cancelling to leading
log.
Once you include this term, it's
cancelling to next leading log.
The whole thing
is mu independent,
getting this from lambda QCD.
So that's end of the aside.
So what I actually
want to do is I
want to come back to our
definition of this MS bar mass,
and I want to treat
it as if we have--
I want to think
about it like an RG.
We have this cutoff.
Let's see if we can write
down an renormalization group
equation for that mass.
It has a cutoff--
there should be some
equation that tells us
how to flow in that cutoff.
Let's see what we
can learn from that.
So that's end of aside.
So we have a cutoff,
and we already
said that we can treat
R as a variable that
parameterizes the mass scheme.
And so we can vary R
in this MSR scheme,
just like we varied u
in the MS bar scheme.
So, if you like,
what you're doing
when you're vary mu
in the MS bar scheme
is you're properly taking
into account kind of what
fluctuations you want
to put into your mass
in the ultraviolet.
And here it's related to
this kind of physics that's
going on in the deep
infrared that you're also
being careful about.
So we'll have instead of a
mu RGE we'll have an R RGE.
The difference between
the mu RGE and the R RGE
is this time we're
talking about powers.
We'll see what happens.
So M pole didn't depend on
R. So you get 0 for that.
And if we just look at
our scheme change formula,
then we can figure
out what the RGE is.
This delta M was a function of
R. And we can define this as R,
to get the dimensions
right, times some kind
of anomalous dimension that's
just a function of alpha.
So what this guy would look
like is again just a series--
some perturbative series.
RGE is writing out our equation.
The equation we've
come to is this.
So R d by dR of the
mass, because of the fact
that we're dealing
with a power, we
get an R on the right-hand
side of this equation.
And that's really
the only thing that's
causing a difference from
this kind of standard RGE's
that we've solved so far.
And the fact that we got
this power, which was 1,
is exactly related to
the fact that it was a u
equals 1/2 renormalon.
If we looked at the renormalons
that are further out,
like u equals 1
would give R squared.
We haven't seen really enough to
identify that, but that's true.
So let's solve this
guy in the usual way.
Integrate on both sides.
From what we just talked about,
R is equal to lambda QCD e
to the minus G of t.
And we can also
therefore write that d
log R is, from this formula.
dt minus G prime of t.
If we follow that through as
a change of variable, that's
the change of variable we get.
So let's switch
variable from R to dt.
So d log R is the
product of these things,
and I can write it actually
kind of a compact way
if I write it is lambda QCD dt d
by dt of e to the minus G of t.
So we've got a G
prime, and then we've
got an e to the minus G of t.
Let's just write that as a
total derivative of that.
So if I write it in terms of
t, then that's the solution.
That's the formal
solution in terms of--
and I switched variable also
in the anomalous dimension.
And that's the formal
solution to the RGE.
And this is a
well-defined integral.
There's no problems
with doing it.
The place where the
integral could start
causing problems is t equals 0.
But we're never
getting to t equals 0.
We have cutoffs that are
keeping us away from t equals 0.
So it shouldn't
surprise you that it's
a well-defined integral, because
we said that these things are
supposed to be well
defined in masses
that are not sensitive to
these renormalon problems.
And taking the
difference of two of them
should again give
us something that's
not sensitive to
renormalon problems.
But it's interesting that you
see lambda QCD popping out.
And that's because these two
masses and the difference
of these cutoffs is
related to absorbing
a different amount of
these fluctuations which
were related to lambda QCD.
So the evolution would just
yield a new well-defined mass
of R1, which absorbs a different
amount of IR fluctuations--
a shell out to R1 instead of
just out to R0 if you like.
So you're absorbing those
fluctuations together with them
M pole to get
something well defined.
And how much you absorb
is related to this cutoff.
So we could do that integral
at whatever order we decide.
Let's just do it at leading log.
So at leading log,
we take this guy
and we just take the first term,
some constant, alpha over 4 pi.
And so gamma R of t,
switching variables,
becomes that constant
over 2 beta 0
if we keep all the factors.
And then a 1 over t--
alpha comes 1 over t.
So if we're at leading
log, we should think
about having the leading log--
we'll have the QCD.
So that's what the 0 means--
there's this factor.
And the integral we'd have
to do would be this one,
e to the minus t over t.
So you see that t equals 0 is
where there could be a problem.
But away from t equals
0, there's no problem.
If you do that integral, it
gives you an incomplete gamma
function.
That's just a way of
saying that there's
a special function that's
defined to be that integral.
Mathematica knows all about it.
It's very useful.
And actually, the
incomplete gamma function
is an example of a function that
has an asymptotic expansion.
So if we look at what happens if
I expand this incomplete gamma
function in alpha, t,
Remember, is 1 over alpha.
It can expand about alpha.
Then it has a series that
has factorial growth.
Let me just write that.
So expanding about alpha
equals 0 is expanding about t
equals infinity.
And the gamma function actually
has an asymptotic expansion.
And if you just work it out,
plug it into Mathematica--
it's a Taylor series--
look at the terms, and
you exactly see this--
2 to the n n factorial, which
is a u equals 1/2 renormalon.
And so what's
happening is when you
take the difference of
two of these gammas,
you're converting this
asymptotic series.
If you take the difference of
two of these asymptotic series,
you're converting it
into a convergent series.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about that next time,
but I'll stop there.
So we can see, from this
renormalization group,
again the renormalon, and
we can see in what way
it's sort of solved by
thinking about making
it shift from here to here.
Because it's the difference
of these two gammas,
not one of them individually.
So we can use normalization
group techniques
to think about these
renormalon effects.
And we'll talk a little bit
more about that next time.
AUDIENCE: So is this a
convergent series now?
IAIN STEWART: The difference
of these is convergent series.
Yeah.
I'll write that down next
time and show you it.